foreign
[Music]
and I think to me that's really
significant this is where the audiences
are this is where the money is
commercial opportunity of the women's
IPL is huge but it's not going to be
profitable from day one and it's not
going to be easy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so the IPL turned cricket from a game
where people were fretting about whether
it had a future about whether it was in
terminal decline into you know one of
the hottest sport properties in the
world I think it is dramatically changed
Cricket for the better
uh first and foremost is
attention spans who are getting shorter
and shorter here comes a nicely packaged
format three hours evening games night
games so you finish work you tune on the
television or you go to the ground every
ball is exciting so there's action all
the time
no other sporting league in the world
has been able to achieve what IPL has
achieved in in about you know 14 15
years I think it's quite remarkable even
when you compare it with with any of the
other leagues in the world because it is
among the top leagues in the world in
terms of actual dollar value you have
hundreds of millions of people tuning in
to watch matches which you can't say
about many other sports taking place
elsewhere in the world so for
broadcasters getting a piece of the IPL
is a game changer especially if you're
an international broadcaster looking to
come into India there's a fan base who
really feel attached to franchises who
feel a sense of ownership of their team
now naturally this sort of gives an
opportunity to diversify into women's
cricket
women cricketers in India have always
played very good Cricket completely away
from public clear and I think what they
have clearly lacked is public adulation
the kind that men's Cricket has always
enjoyed in this country
[Music]
is
29 years old and my medium
foreign
that was a really important step in
order to show that they're serious about
making sure the women have the same
opportunities as men when they're
playing you know at the highest levels
you know there's a lot to talk about
equal pay in women's sport in general
for me it's equal opportunity and I
think that's what we're now starting to
see in women's sport is that women and
girls are getting more opportunity to do
the things that young boys or young men
were doing from maybe a younger age
[Music]
my name is I am a bowling all rounder
starting major crickets
[Music]
we're kind of making girls learn the
hard way because they've not had the
opportunity to play in front of many
crowds in front of well on TV
consistently that's what the game has
needed we've needed to push it on
quickly
it's obviously a bigger challenge to
sort of commercialize the you know
women's game in the same way as the
men's game and so it's important to have
perspective on this take England for
example just look at the growth of the
Women's Premier League in England in
terms of the viewership in terms of the
deals in terms of the value and then
think about how that's translated into
England's success at the Euros this
summer
there's just a lot more talk about
women's sport and for the first time I
heard The Narrative of this game of
football tonight and it wasn't women are
playing football it was just a game of
football
the main difference between the women's
IPL and men's IPL is that it was easier
to commercialize and make money right
from the word go in the case of women's
Cricket it is a little bit of an unknown
territory
Frankly Speaking we are not looking at
the commercial aspect to begin with
we are wanting to create a great
property out of this tournament we are
wanting to give opportunities to our
women characters
foreign
the you know attitude towards women in
India has been changing but very slowly
India still tends to be traditional you
know rather conservative Society where
women are expected to get educated have
a career until they get married but
after that they should just make home
look after their family and not really
think very passionately about their
careers that is what the society at
large would expect of women but things
are changing because Financial pressures
are increasing women are becoming more
assertive attitudes have started
changing but very slowly
foreign
definitely
definitely yes
so book stories
foreign
[Music]
if the women's IPL doesn't work out for
whatever reason whether this season or
later Seasons it'll be a blue it'll be a
big disappointment but it's not going to
stop the rise of women's Cricket in
India which is happening one way or the
other profits would eventually come we
are very sure of that given the interest
that we have got with regard to
franchises from the media groups and
from the sponsorship point of view there
are things that you can draw from which
is essentially what is happening to
men's and women's sports around the
globe whether it's basketball or soccer
or whatever so that also gives you it's
a good indicator of where it might land
and but the sentiment is definitely
positive better marketing around women's
Cricket creates a virtuous cycle so you
get more fans interested more people
tuning in to watch the matches or going
to the stadiums right that in turn gets
broadcasters interested broadcasters are
willing to spend more money on the
rights to broadcast those games then you
get advertisers interested because they
want to get the eyeballs that are
watching the matches then you get the
sponsors who want to put money into the
teams that Finds Its way to the players
the top level players and then
ultimately that then trickles down right
into the Grassroots where these teams in
order to stay competitive need to start
investing in the next generation of
talent and that's the kind of virtuous
cycle that that we can hope to see in
the coming years
certainly for young kids and young
females you can't be what you can't see
and the fact that there's women on TV
now doing things as special as what the
guys are doing I think is is really
inspiring
[Applause]
so Australia and England are at the top
of the rankings of women's Cricket
around the world and that's because
they've done more until now to build up
leagues to put in the money to grow the
infrastructure and the ecosystem I'm
quite hopeful that with this tournament
would go a long way in making our team
more competitive we have seen them
performing exceedingly well in the
recently and Commonwealth game than in
England series and then in Asia cup and
I'm quite hopeful it will make our team
better and they would make sure that
whatever our men team has been able to
achieve they achieve more than that
I think with the women's IPL there is a
good chance that that India become one
of the bigger powerhouses of the women's
game
with that as well you get more
opportunities and overseas player to go
and play in these tournaments so I think
I think there's benefits to be had for
everyone
playing Cricket in India is crazy but
when I say crazy it's incredible it's
like nothing you'll experience anywhere
else when you come to India you can feel
the energy around Cricket like nothing
else it gives you such a pulse of the
country and the fact that if we can go
over as overseas players and be a part
of that then it's only gonna
increase my you know exposure as a
player it's going to increase my ability
because there's more opportunity to play
in front of crowds and Under Pressure
um and that's exciting I think the
combination of the national and the
international that balance I think is
most important the international
tournaments like World Cup and
television broadcasting of women's games
it's very exciting to see the growth of
women's Cricket in England than
Australia is great but in order for
women's Cricket to succeed on a global
level India needs to be at the center
foreign
[Music]